well how about we how about we do one
more we talk about Jack Dorsey real
quick yes I do want to talk about
because we're we'll get to the Super
chats next we'll probably go a little
bit longer than we usually do yeah but
this is actually a really cool story is
worth talking about for sure I think
Jack isn't okay dude I mean my respect
to him I mean I don't know him I don't
know anything about him this is the
first thing that I know about him other
than the fact that he started Twitter
that's it Jack Dorsey is not Mark
Zuckerberg right so mark runs Facebook
for all of their problems it comes down
to Mark Zuckerberg Jack Dorsey was fired
from Twitter a long time ago they
brought him back and I am convinced he's
not very active he's the CEO of square
and Twitter but I really doubt he's
involved in Twitter like he's probably
to a certain degree but you know people
are was tweeting at Jack when something
bad happens on Twitter and they're
blaming him for it and I think you can
criticize him because you know if he
wants to be the face of the company be
the CEO then he has to you know expect
people will criticize him for sure but I
don't think he really has anything to do
with it so CNBC reports Twitter CEO set
aside 1 billion dollars in square equity
for charity coronavirus relief hey man
that's how much is too much
that is incredible that's that's it I
mean for the for the billionaires for
the the 0.1% I believe right exactly for
that for that small little literal 1% of
human beings that have that amount of
wealth if they could even spend it in
their lifetime I don't even know if it's
possible but for this man to give up
almost a third of it yeah just you know
just to help everyone that's that's
props man that was amazing well grab the
context and then we'll we'll talk about
it they say Square and Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey said Tuesday he will set aside 1
billion dollars in his Square equity to
support relief efforts for kovat 19 and
other causes once the pandemic is over
in a series of tweets Dorsey said that
after the pandemic is over he will
dedicate the money to causes like
universal basic income and girls health
and education he said he's pulling the
shares from his stake in square instead
of Twitter because he owns more stock in
square Dorsey said he'll cash in the
shares over time the impact of his money
the impact this money will have should
benefit both companies over the long
term because
helping the people we want to serve door
she said that he wants to see the impact
of his donation during his lifetime and
that the needs are increasingly urgent
he also said he hopes it will inspire
others to do something similar that's
the others I was talking about the
others who have that that don't need it
first there's his choices there's
politics in this for sure he's a lucky
dude the girls and women's education
stuff yeah yeah but look if some dude
makes a ton of money that wants to
donate it to whatever whatever cause
they want to I really don't enjoy that
said welcome to capitalism he's got the
money can spend how he sees fit but
there was this funny meme where I guess
Bill Gates donated 50 million mhm and
people are like Bill Gates is worth what
is he worth like 60 70 billion dollars
something and he gives away like 70
billion is that them I don't know you
want can you look up what Bill Gates is
no but a lot more than Jack Dorsey right
right right so so if T million is like
chump change for someone like him Jack
Dorsey is a pretty lefty dude and I
think there's a lot of people like him
that are good
Nate good-spirited okay misguided
perhaps and that can lead to really
negative things you know they say the
path to hell is paved with good
intentions you know this I did this I
think is respectable because uh I
remember seeing like Oprah for instance
giving out cars and everyone's like oh
that's so amazing Oprah's giving
everybody cars and all that stuff and
it's like she's not giving anybody
anything dude yeah the car company is
doing it's a promo they're using a show
to market the product yep now everyone's
gonna be driving around and they pay
taxes on it he had all of a sudden all
of a sudden people had like a tax
liability of like five five thousand
dollars of some ridiculous number they
couldn't pay and so they were like
selling them but if not just that she's
a billionaire so when she gives away
like you know a couple hundred thousand
dollars it's like it is a lot of money I
get it but relative to how much she's
earned right you know when I see
somebody who's making a minimum wage
give up a hundred bucks a week then
that's that's legit it's like a huge
portion and your income is probably
irresponsible so they say Dorsey said he
wants to see the impact of his donation
during his lifetime and that Vanita I
read that Dorsey also tweeted a link to
public a public a Google Doc where
people can track which organization the
funds money will go to that's how that's
surprising and obviously like you can
actually check it out Dorsey isn't the
only
technologists to fund coronavirus relief
efforts though he's doing it on a big
scale Amazon's Jeff Bezos has said he is
donating a hundred million to US food
banks now stop right there for a second
Bezos has shares his access is like 130
billion or something ridiculous number
door c3 so I'll give some respect to
Jack Dorsey yeah Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg and his wife Priscilla
donated 25 million towards creating
treatments for Crona virus through their
philanthropic philanthropic organization
the Chan Zuckerberg initiative and the
Bill Gates Foundation has said it will
spend billions to fight corona virus
according to The Wall Street Journal
Jack Dorsey has done way more than
anyone else in regards to actually you
know doing right by this and having met
the guy and talked to him mm-hmm I think
there are issues with Twitter I think he
absolutely needs to step up I don't know
if he can I think he's more of a figure
like I said like a mascot yeah the
criticism for him if he wants to be the
CEO is is is legit but this is this is
cool I mean how many people are willing
to give up that a 30% of their total net
worth when there's like a real emergency
or something
I mean probably the ratio is really
small because 30 percent of your net
worth for most people is like they would
go bankrupt you know most people already
are negative exactly so there's a
negative exactly from something I was
reading this this I think was from like
Forbes okay and it was talking about the
net worth of people based on age okay 29
was when their net worth went positive
$1000 on average like if you're 29 your
net worth is like a thousand bucks Wow
and it's mostly because of college or
just because a lot I don't have money
right but yeah from like 18 until 28
negative net worth and then you know
what you enter 30 and I have a thousand
dollars in that 31 you've got like
$7,000 and then by the time they're 40
they have like $50,000 so for all of
these years of working they finally flip
it positive yeah Jack Dorsey how old is
that guy he's like is he 40 I think yeah
it looks like he could be 40 yeah and so
he started up pick up a bunch of
companies made a bunch of money
3:43 so his net worth is certainly
higher than a lot of people now this
will be interesting because he might say
he wants to a bunch of good things of
this but what do you think happens when
you when you just pour window money out
of window right reminds me of that that
Family Guy episode where Peter gets in
the blimp with Brian and they dump bags
of money into the football stadium oh
yeah and in that episode and the
neighborhood's fighting over it and
hitting each other and it causes chaos
and pandemonium so what happens now with
him giving up this wealth like will it
work I don't write and where's it gonna
go what organizations do i maybe we can
actually just pull up the Google Doc is
this gonna yes looks like it's gonna hey
there we go
so America's food fund oh I guess no
he's choosing but you can watch what
he's done with it okay wow that's a lot
of money so it's there and it's yes well
it's the Google Doc the numbers are
there see maybe this will actually help
people understand how stock works maybe
they'll understand liquid cash or
something I don't know maybe not because
he set aside a billion dollars worth of
the value how many shares is that no
idea it is he doing it by value of
current share price is 50 bucks yep oh
that's a lot of shares so he set aside
and then it says number of shares to be
transferred almost twenty thousand
nineteen thousand eight hundred and
thirty three Oh No nineteen million
sorry I thought that was a period yeah
okay seen million shares cylinder what
happens what happens now if because he's
dumping these stocks people start
selling square yeah that's not gonna
tank and then it's like all of a sudden
now the current value is only 200
million yeah no I might not take it
might go up but him selling twenty
million shares yeah that typically is
gonna drop the price abstention it's
tricky so I'm not an expert on trading
but when there's a massive sell-off the
way it works is like you have you have
you have bids so ever like let's save a
hundred people one person says I'll pay
a dollar next person says I'll pay two
and it goes to a hundred so right now
the current bid to buy is a hundred
bucks
so if I say I'm gonna sell a stock I saw
it $400 the next available is 99 the
next stock sales $4.99 every time you
sell the value of your stock drops next
so there'll be people who specifically
say oh what's this Jack Dorsey is
selling square stuck at 50 bucks a share
I'm gonna put in an order to buy once it
hits 40 bucks because it's definitely
gonna tank and then once it sells off
and the prices going back up I'll have
bought it in a premium so now you're
probably to see a bunch of people moving
to buy at lower prices I'm speculating
and then the total value will drop
dramatically we'll see if it actually
works out I think it's cool these doing
it the politics of it would help drive
up the value of the company at all and I
don't think it could be a I mean look
he's personally giving up a lot of money
regardless of what the value of the
stock is it's his but it's personally
his how much how much stock does he have
left in the company presumably a bit
more maybe even other 20 million shares
and how much does he is he is he hoping
this might actually drive up the value
but I'll tell you what man I respect it
you know why I've been thinking about a
long time about a really great marketing
game like a marketing plan mm-hmm where
companies would compete to do the most
social good and you imagine if like
McDonald's we have like a budget a
ridiculous budget for a commercial
million bucks two million bucks I'm like
what could you do with that in terms of
social good hmm what if instead of doing
a commercial where the rock shows up in
a parachute and breaks through the roof
of McDonald's and then orders a Big Mac
I'm just being silly what if instead of
paying all that money you took a cell
phone and filmed yourself out you know
filmed yourself paying people's medical
bills and then you know you know what I
would do if I was a company I was gonna
do an ad I'd be like for the next 30
seconds you're gonna watch us go around
and pay off people's medical debt and
then when we in the last 10 seconds I'll
be alike this was a commercial for our
product straight up we did this we spent
a million bucks paying up people's
medical debt to get your attention
because we want you to buy our
cheeseburgers I'm not saying it's a good
idea I prefer commercials where people
are like buy our cheeseburger because
it's got beef and cheese on it yeah but
if you look at how much money they spend
on stupid things like a zebra breaks
through you know the
no and then like Mountain Dew is
exploding through the pipes and people
are like well we spend all that money I
would I would I would be actually I
would actually be more inclined to buy
the product if they were like instead of
wasting all that money we filmed an
extremely low-budget commercial and
helped a bunch of people you know if we
found some people who are you know lost
their jobs and we helped them start a
business you know I'd be like and this
is not an actor I'm actually the CEO of
the company yes I'm talking about my
community if they had a 30-second
commercial where the guy was like I am
straight up and unashamedly to telling
you that we dumped this money in an
effort to get your attention because we
figured what better way to get your
attention than to literally spend money
doing something really really great they
can't be ignored and so hey it's a
win-win right bunch of homeless people
get helped you guys figure out we got a
product like actually remember went I
think was KFC that's monetizing virtue
signaling some why not yeah I know it's
remember one like the best case scenario
for signaling like we were going to
spend money but instead we helped a lot
of people here's our product yeah was
like remember what was it was it KFC was
fixing potholes mmm-hmm what was a
delivery company to company yeah
Domino's
they were like wolf of the pothole and
then put our logo on it I'm like angry
oh really
yeah because they were like why why is
the pizza like they call it late stage
capitalism that pizza companies are
required to fix the stuff and I'm like
required to I'm like that's actually
great yeah like they have know that it's
it works you walk outside there's a
Domino's thing on the street and you're
like that's silly oh hey they fixed that
potholes somebody got a flat tire and
they show up next day in P Domino's is
fixing it they're like hey awesome
thanks Domino's well we'll see we'll see
how it plays out I mean I regardless of
what's going on I think it's cool
politics aside yeah I think I think I
guess I have another question we can we
can a little bit longer how much is too
much you know question like like profit
like how much does a human really need
to make before they're like I don't need
to make any more money every single dime
that I would have made after this point
after this amount goes to charities not
even is that what you're talking about
not even about charities necessarily not
necessarily chair why would I trust
every you know
true-true giving it to the things that I
want to do like what he's doing with
this you know Google chart you can see
where the money's going so like Jack
Dorsey literally couldn't buy anything
else like I guess I guess he could
because a billion you know if you want
to go to Mars I guess he can give Elon a
billion dollars and get that first-class
ticket
sure but there are things you can't buy
no matter how rich you are there are
limits I don't know if it the goal of
all these billionaires is to like
eventually get to the point where they
can buy a rocket tomorrow Monica's doing
scene altered carbon yeah dude that's
what they want
well if Jack Dorsey was you know he's
like I would like to download my brain
into a chip that can plant in other
bodies and transfer my consciousness
yeah you need him up you're gonna you're
gonna need a bit more than a billion
dollars probably might not be possible
but you know no no you're saying what
would they need or want and it's like
that's probably the last the only thing
remaining is immortality because they
have everything but do people really
want to be immortal
those people I feel like it's a myth
when you have power you don't want to
let it go
so greed corrupts right but I feel like
not everybody gets corrupted to the
point of that I was the immortal to have
power forever well I was watching
something where they said that everybody
who's young doesn't want to die and once
you get older and life gets harder and
you're in pain yeah then you're like I
don't want to be immortal well that's
because you're in pain but if you were
constantly 24 you probably always want
to live yeah exactly
so it doesn't doesn't Peter teal do like
youth blood transfusions oh gosh there's
an urban legend I have no idea I do not
mean to impugn the integrity of Peter
Thiel I just a story I heard or that
like what is that can you look this up
you know adrenochrome know I don't know
I'm not saying it is a thing but that's
that's that's the vibe of like otherwise
they would be after there's there's a
story wet not waste at me but
billionaires in Silicon Valley hire
young people to exercise and be healthy
and eat healthy and then once a week
they transfer blood they trade blood Wow
so I have four articles here one says
teal is very very interested in young
people's blood
says he is not harvesting the blood of
the young he wants to inject himself and
the fourth said the FDA is warning
against this Wow so I don't really know
it well so the idea is that by in
transfusing youthful blood mm-hmm it
actually repairs like your blood is now
younger and so it's healthier and it
makes your body doesn't seem to make
sense how to make sense yeah yeah maybe
it's just an urban legend but that's
what people were always saying yeah so
something there I don't know but maybe
some people do want to be immortal
maybe they'll eat healthy because of it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you